вітаємо Ласкаво просимо на Європу У
фокусі Ми раді що ви приєдналися до
нас безліч бізнесів продовжують
намагатися потрапити до Європи ризикуючи
своїм
життям взимку подорож до іспанських
канарських островів Особливо небезпечна
тим не менш невеликий острів ілієро
повідомляє про безпрецедентне збільшення
кількості
біженців моду молодий синагалець прибув
на цей острів роки тому але його мрія
почати нове життя Ще не
здійснилося працівниця служби допомоги
біженцям Тесей де падрон та її чоловік
гільберто добре знайомі з такими
історіями і деякі залишають їх емоційно
виснаженими цей порт на Гран канарія має
особливе значення для моду він із
сенегалу і як і багато інших
західноафриканців прибув сюди на
маленькому переповненому рибальському
човні
цього року десятки тисяч людей здійснили
таку небезпечну
подорож усе про що я подумав тоді я
помру якщо не сьогодні то завтра Я
відчував небезпеку в якій ми були можете
собі уявити чо вінту піднімався вгору то
падав вниз Іноді він майже розвалювався
на частини люди
плакали усе про що я міг думати Це моя
мама що я більше ніколи її не
побачу моду пережив цю небезпечну для
життя переправу але його Надія потрапити
на материкову частину Іспанії щоб почати
нове життя поступово
згасала минуло цілих три роки відтоді як
він прибув на Канари а моду досі не може
звідси виїхати увесь цей час сюди
продовжують причалювати човни із
Західної Африки цього року таку подорож
здійснило близько 35 сяч людей удвічі
більше ніж то рік багато хто прибуває з
пораненнями сотні гинуть у морі
переправа із Західної Африки на
Канарські острови вважається одним із
найнебезпечніших маршрутів до Європи
Хуан Мігель падрон стикається з цією
реальністю щодня він мер Ель ієро
найменшого із островів зараз він їде на
цвинтар на черговий похорон мігранта
який загинув у
морі Я радий що ми можемо поховати їх
тут разом з іншими членами нашої громади
але мені сумно адже ми не знаємо їхніх
імен їхні надробки порожні а це означає
що ніхто не зможе знайти свого чоловіка
свою дитину чи
брата мати і брат моду досі у сенегалі
він сумує за ними і каже що більше
ніколи не буде ризикувати життям
переправляючись на човні
Ви ставите на кін своє життя декому це
вдається але багатьом Ні я втратив
стількох моїх друзів у
морі я намагався застерегти їх але вони
не
слухали ці історії та Сейді падрон та її
чоловікові дуже добре
знайомі вони волонтери і зараз
займаються підготовкою нового притулку у
колишньому монастирі але місця на
острові не
вистачає що
залишилося підготувати
ліжка скласти
[музика]
аптечки Так давай спочатку подивимося
скільки чого є тоді ми зможемо вирішити
де розмістити немовлят жінок і дітей
поранених треба розміщувати на першому
поверсі а інших на другому
добре це пором до тенеріфа який
перевозить сотні біженців на більший
острів очікується що їх буде ще
більше їх так багато що ми просто не
можемо про них подбати припливає один
човен ви даєте всім воду і відводите їх
в душ потім приплив і ще один човен 280
людей треба знову реорганізовуватися
шукати де можна знайти більше ліжок це
важко багато хто прибуває хворим або
пораненим буквально кілька днів помер
чоловік яким опікувалася
тесейда Це сильний удар ти починаєш
думати А чи можна було зробити
більше чи варто було перевірити їх ще
раз цієї
ночі Ми зустрічаємо їх знайомимося з
ними а потім це
важко моду визнали економічним мігра
йому Відмовили у наданні статусу біженця
а це означає що його
депортують біженці з інших країн можуть
пробути тут місяць чи два після чого їм
дозволять виїхати на
материк Але ми з сенегалу а там немає
війни Тож нам сказали ми повинні
повернутися до своєї
країни моду не має законних підстав
залишатися в країні але поки що він тут
і працює кравцем його прихистив знайомий
але ця ситуація пригнічує
його моя сім'я постійно просить грошей
але ж ти тепер в Європі кажуть вони та
уявлення африканців про Європу має мало
спільного з
реальністю якщо ти живеш тут і маєш
документи то можеш мати хороше життя але
в іншому випадку в тебе немає нічого а я
стільки всього там покинув у мене була
хороша робота в сенегалі але я все
втратив
моду сподівається що все це було
недаремно але поки що за словами хлопця
його мрія про краще життя у Європі не
здійснилася за рівнем забруднення
повітря босні і Герцеговина одна з
найгірших в Європі Ця країна має багаті
поклади бурого вугілля це вугілля
використовується зокрема і на найбільшій
Україні електростанції у тузлі ця
електростанція магає задовольнити значну
частину потреб країни в електроенергії і
забезпечує тисячі людей в регіоні
стабільною роботою однак місцеві жителі
такі як ізт почали висловлювати
занепокоєння щодо стану свого здоров'я
серед населення яке проживає поблизу
електростанції зростає кількість
випадків раку та проблем із дихальними
шляхами тож наскільки токсичне таке
сусідство насправді
[музика]
[оплески]
гіна збирає останні помідори У цьому
сезоні вона каже що вони вже не такі
смачні як у серпні їй 74 роки і вона
живе сама її Будинок знаходиться поруч
із найбільшою вугільною електростанцією
в Боснії і
герцеговині мені доводиться вирощувати
власні
овочі Я погано ходжу а супермаркет
далеко коли я щось збираю Я все добре
мию тричі і їм
я не думаю що це
небезпечно А вона розповідає мені що має
чотирьох курей і двох котів які
складають її компанію після смерті
чоловіка Мій чоловік помер від раку
шлунку у 2018
році але я не знаю що стало
причиною з одного боку від будинку
знаходиться вугільна електростанція з
іншого боку її золовідвал це місце куди
скидають попіл з електростанції
це зовсім поруч із містом але здається
що до нього так далеко як до
[музика]
Місяця Ми зустрічаємо Деніса зісько він
екологічний активіст і вже багато років
виступає проти цієї
електростанції
Отже Що ви можете сказати про
це цей попіл отруйний я б помив руки
після цього там повно важких металів
кадмій миш'як свинець усе це небезпечно
для
здоров'я То мені краще викинути це
тактак і Помийте ваші руки але не цією
водою попіл зі станції викачують разом
із водою цей басейн і імовірно попіл
залишиться тут назавжди Деніс розповідає
що згідно з дослідженням яке він провів
разом із вченим з університету Тузли ця
суміш містить цілу низку важких металів
Він каже що Ця вода токсична і
надзвичайно Лужна тому вона не повинна
контактувати з підземними
водами і як цей басейн
запечатаний вони нещодавно побудували
дамбу в кінці долини але на жаль ніщо не
закриває дно Ого басейну і ось тут і
виникає проблема тому що це мало б бути
зроблено так вони мали покласти
підкладку яка б запобігала проникненню
цієї води у підземні води чого не було
зроблено Деніс регулярно приїжджає сюди
щоб документувати цю ділянку Він боїться
що важкі метали потраплять у ґрунт
ґрунтові води і зрештою у харчовий
ланцюг Ми хочемо дізнатися чи порушує
цей золовідвал правові
норми згідно з нашим законодавством це
законно На
жаль екологічні дозволи Вони все роблять
відповідно до цих екологічних
дозволів тож проблема яку ми маємо в цій
країні полягає у тому що вся система
фактично працює на захист забруднювачів
а не на захист людей і
природи ми запитуємо в компанії чи є
якась герметизація і отримуємо ухильну
відповідь мовляв вони дотримуються у
всіх норм щоб перевірити ці твердження
звертаємося до Міністерства екології та
природних ресурсів із проханням надати
нам офіційну оцінку впливу цього об'єкта
на довкілля нам кажуть що не можуть
надати цей документ забруднення води та
ґрунту - це одна з проблем але
забруднення повітря ще більша проблема
окрім електростанції свій внесок у
забруднення вносять транспорт побутове
опалення та інші галузі промисловості
Тузла вважається одними з найбільш
забруднених міст Європи приїжджаючи туди
ми одразу відчуваємо дивний запах у
повітрі за даними електростанції вона не
порушує жодних законодавчих норм але
показники вмісту твердих частинок у
повітрі під час нашого візиту часто
виходять за межі прийнятних для здоров'я
норм і ще одна людина яка глибоко
стурбована забрудненням повітря ізт
барчич який живе неподалік від
електростанції Він хоче показати свої
проблеми зі здоров'ям тут мені прорізали
чотири ребра
він хворіє вже понад 20 років і підозрює
що причина цього саме
станція Я втратив частину легені У мене
був рак
туберкульоз і все через цю станцію
гарантую це все через
електростанцію Я тут
народився коли був дитиною сніг був
чорний у 70-х
роках
А тепер дощ повний
пилу іет показує фотографії своєї
операції за його словами зараз у нього
залишилася лише половина об'єму легень
він не хоче щоб станцію закрили але
вимагає кращого захисту йому доводиться
приймати багато ліків і виходити на
вулицю лише тоді коли рівень забруднення
низькийлікарівітьрекомендували мені
переїхати звідси якщо є така можливість
Але куди ж я
переїду у місцевій лікарні пульмонолог і
токсиколог сефіка у міханіч лікує
пацієнтів які живуть у цьому районі я
показую їй рівень дрібнодисперсних
частинок за останні дні він у Червоній
зоні аж до 200 що це означає для вашого
здоров'я для мого здоров'я для здоров'я
будь-кого
тут
Це набагато вище ніж допустимий максимум
для такого розміру
частинок принципі ніяка кількість цього
не є здоровою для
людини чим вища концентрація і чим
довший вплив тим серйозніше і триваліші
[музика]
наслідки дрібні тварді частинки які
також називають пм2.5 можуть призводити
до раку серцево-судинних захворювань
діабету і в цілому до часної смерті я
хочу дізнатися чи можна кількісно
визначити скільки шкоди завдає ця
електростанція А скільки інші фактори
такі як дорожній
рухцетуа я не можу назвати вам відсоток
тому що немає
даних Якщо говорити про територію
навколо електростанції то забруднення
повітря вище ніж в інших частинах
міста
сама електростанція безумовно має
негативний вплив на якість
повітря Але це співставно зншимирелами
забрудня проте багато місцевих жителів
вважають саме електростанцію головним
винуватцем на вулиці ізета мешканці
розуміють що ми тут аби поговорити про
електростанцію І несподівано У кожного з
них виникло бажання висловитись вони
розпові нам що у кожного є хворі або
покійні члени
сім'ї нас тут труять у мене мама померла
цей сусід помер його син помер їй
зробили операцію і подивіться на
ситуацію
ізета інший чоловік зупиняється на
своєму авто щоб висловити свою думку Він
за вугільну
електростанцію починається палка
дискусія
вони не можуть закрити електростанцію
зараз цей регіон і люди тут залежать від
неї її закриття означатиме кінець
видобутку корисних
копалин це означатиме втрату робочих
місць і що ми отримуємо в результаті
бідність і хтось згори вирішуватиме Коли
відкривати А коли закривати
труби сьогодні країна яка експортує
енергію це багата
країна але звідти йдето
Вони мають встановити кращі фільтри щоб
нам було легше жити і
дихати особливо взимку неможливо
дихати ми задихаємося я ходила до
багатьох лікарів Вони казали що це не
дивно знаючи де я живу Ми просто хочемо
бути здоровими ми ходимо як
зомбі Боснія і Герцеговина має величезні
запаси вугілля Минулого року Вона
експортувала ч виробленої енергії
економічна вигода для місцевих жителів
Утім здається незначною у тузлі проживає
понад 100 000 мешканців але за даними
компанії
електропведа лише 370 робітників станції
місцеві керівництво компанії не бажає
давати телеінтерв'ю на наші запитання
вони відповідають поштою підкреслюючи що
дотримуються всіх вимог законодавства
однак так само як і Міністерство
екології вони не надають нам даних про
викиди пm2
дрібнодисперсних
частинок незважаючи на численні випадки
онкологічних захворювань важко юридично
довести зв'язок між електростанцією та
хворобами людей Я хочу отримати
відповіді від інституту громадського
здоров'я кантону але і там не отримую
чітких
[музика]
роз'яснень потрібні дослідження щоб
оцінити вплив виробників енергії на
здоров'я людей
[музика]
але Ані держава Ані кантон Не виділяють
на це достатньо фінансових
ресурсів ми просимо гроші але ніхто не
хоче нам їх
давати єдине дослідження яке було
зроблено проводила екологічна
організація і у них був дуже невеликий
бюджет складається враження що офіційні
установи та державні органи заплющують
очі або перекладають провину
гіна живе повільним життям Іноді вона
страждає від бронхіту Але жінка не
тримає зла на вугільну
електростанцію Мені подобається тут жити
Це я знаю
точно жінка змирилася з тим де вона
живе у моєму віці у тебе немає великих
мрій ти борешся щоб зробити наступний
крок щоб ходити щоб
[музика]
вставати минуло 50 років відтоді як тут
побудували електростанцію я від'їжджаю з
думкою як виглядатиме ситуація в тузлі
для наступних
поколінь знайомтеся юель голландський
терапевт що вдихає життя людей похилого
віку які проживають у місцевому будинку
для літніх людей
юель вважає важливим щоб вони виходили
за рамки крісел їдалень і
спалень він відвідує будинок для літніх
людей в Роттердамі де помітив як Віки
хвороби пов'язані з рухом накладають
обмеження дивлячись на те що Юль дістає
зі свого багажника важко здогадатися чим
він заробляє на життя Можливо він клоун
аніматор на дитячих
святах насправді він використовує ці
штуки щоб підняти навіть найлінивіших з
диванів і змусити їх порухатися і коли
він з'являється його пацієнти знають
навіщо він
[музика]
прийшов мешканці одразу впізнають ці
ходунки Коли я приходжу сюди з усіма
Цими речами Вони одразу впізнають мене
дюель повернувся мене і мої речі справді
впізнають
[музика]
мешканці цього будинку для літніх людей
у ротердамі мають обмежену фізичну
мобільність більшість із них могли б
рухатися більше але просто не хочуть
Сандра виняток вона крутить педалі цього
велотренажера і насолоджується
голландськими краєвидами що пропливають
повз неї це хороше фізичне навантаження
але трохи нудне тому Юль будує для
сандри поле для гри у мінігольф це
заняття Їй дуже
подобається терапія використовується для
лікування людей зокрема коли вони мають
проблеми з опорно-руховим апаратом ми ж
займаємося профілактичною медициною ми
працюємо над тим щоб люди рухалися для
них фізкультура просто необхідна але
робити фітнес обов'язковим це часто не
спрацьовує тож я відповідаю за те щоб їм
було цікаво щоб вони поверталися знову і
знову нахилитися зосередитися і
прицілитися це вимагає певних зусиль
обличчя сандри почервоніло не просто від
хвилювання так
виняток Якщо говорити про догляд за
хворими Він дуже відданий і повністю
занурений у
справу він постійно носиться зі своїми
речами і їх використовує щоб заохотити
людей рухатися і він сповнений
ідей з ним дуже приємно
працювати один із найскладніших хн він
часто лежить у ліжку цілими
днями Привіт хенку я приніс тобі свою
гумову стрічку будеш
займатися Це ще й хороший спосіб
поскладати
[музика]
речі коли Хенк лежить у ліжку а я
заходжу до нього щось відбувається в
його
мозку він стає більш
уважним якщо я залишаюся поруч він стає
активним часто Він навіть стає з ліжка і
допомагає наприклад з приготуванням їжі
або
прибиранням поїздка на велосипеді із Лем
робить Лідію щасливою вона любить бувати
на свіжому
повітрі сидячи вдома Вона почувається
сумно завідувач служби догляду каже що
робота юеля допомагає
[музика]
всім звісно команда теж отримує користь
тому що ми багато Працюємо з цими
людьми Ми повинні підняти їх з ліжка і
забезпечити їм хороший розпорядок
дня якщо вони здоровіші і менше важать
то й почуваються
краще тоді вони щасливіші і більш охоч
приймають допомогу і
догляд це покращує всю робочу атмосферу
поки юель катається на велосипеді його
асистентка фемке підміняє його у ролі
живого баскетбольного кільця для
йоупа донька фемке ТЕС часто
приєднується до них підтримуючи
Командний
дух Я думаю що всім хочеться погратися
кожен у душі залишається
дитиною і ця внутрішня дитина змушує
людей тут забути про свій вік І недуги
хоча б на деякий
час коли я думаю про турецькі десерти на
думку одразу спадають такі ласощі як
пахлава та лукум але я б ніколи не
подумав про бельгійські вафлі в
Туреччині кемаль уста відомий дуже
успішний пекар вафель
істамбула він не просто добре володіє
своїм ремеслом але й розуміється на
саморекламі особливо зараз у сезон
різдвяних свят
і на цьому Ми завершуємо цей випуск
Європу У фокусі Дякуємо за перегляд і до
нових
[музика]
зустрічей